larry king he died
and uh i saw one news article i think
was the daily mail that says larry
king dies after battling covet and i'm
like wait larry king died of covid
i clicked the article larry king had
covert like eight weeks ago and got over
it
yeah but the way they they titled it
technically was true
well i mean that's what they do it's how
the media is
but i mean it's it is like
even though i would say it's a little
disingenuous whatever
it is i think relevant when you're that
old
to be like the let because i mean to be
fair the last
known larry king health thing was
covered
so it was like oh yeah he did literally
just announced a few weeks ago that he
had covet and then he
he died but that guy survived cance like
four cancers and like nine heart attacks
and
that dude was a beast hey hank aaron got
the vaccine and then he died
yeah hank aaron baseball player hey
karen when did he die
he died on friday why do i feel like
hank darren's died like 50 times hank
aaron died friday
i feel like i've heard that announcement
no no he actually
maybe a hoax but he actually died on
friday uh a couple weeks after getting
the covet vaccine so i'm also gonna make
irresponsible connections
and we're back with fox news alert and
our top story this morning as we told
you earlier this hour
radio and tv legend larry king has died
the iconic host passed away this morning
at a hospital in los angeles
this guy was a legend look i so whatever
you i love
larry king was one of the best
interviewers
on the planet larry king the larry king
show on cnn was one of the best shows
ever like you can't
like you can i know i know like because
i tweeted the same thing like the day he
died i was like man rest in peace like
he was a legend like i'm legit
i'm legit a fan of larry king and then
of course you just get like 15 replies
pointing
like which thank you by the way because
i had no idea larry king was jewish
wait what i know i take back what i said
i wasn't aware
the well-studied geniuses of twitter
decided that they would uh fill me in on
that they would illuminate me on that
fact
um yeah i know guys i know
well larry king started doing radio in
south florida no local radio in south
florida he started as a dj
and then he started doing a talk show
and he actually got into a very famous
feud
with neil rogers who was a huge raid
another by the way also jewish
huge radio legend in south florida a
really funny guy but they got into a
feud i don't remember what it was for
but
when neil rogers money rogers found out
that larry king remember he got arrested
for like a five thousand dollar gambling
debt or something
that effect uh he would always have this
clip from from
larry king that was loamy fifty dollars
and it was just a running joke forever
and he hated the guy
um larry king's interviewed everybody
too to say that larry king just did it's
not like larry king just interviewed
lefty people like larry king has
interviewed everybody
he has he's had everybody on the show
and i don't think he was very
he kind of just was good at asking
questions i don't think he was very
intrigued at least during interviews
very
interject your own opinion guy you know
no you just had personal conversations
with people that's why people liked
watching larry king
yeah because he didn't he didn't prep
for a show he didn't do
any of that [ __ ] he just he would just
hang out with the people and be like you
know
what's your golf game like 80 well i
mean 87 he was another one that like
[ __ ]
i think he's like a four-year-old like
this guy was [ __ ] having no yeah he
has
laid in line like larry king
would keep marrying these 30 year olds
and just dump and [ __ ] in them which is
admirable giving props for that yeah
that's right he interviewed slipknot's
guitar player like he's interviewed
everybody hospital in los angeles
he hosted several shows including larry
king live not familiar with it
earlier this month king was hospitalized
after testing positive for covet 19.
but his cause of death has not been
announced king was 87 years old
such sad news seeing this tomorrow about
larry king too he's part of that
generation we're gonna
we're gonna lose of people that um
that have like an innocent racism to
them too yes
like we're gonna i'm gonna miss having
guys like larry king being like
yeah i came in the other day and you
know the colored fella
that does that works in the lobby he
actually it was his birthday and i
i got the colored fella card you go
larry you can't you can't say that
it's cnn in 2012 we're glad you're
visiting bro
but like you can't be saying that [ __ ]
in the hallways probably always tipped
them well and everything too
but he was also you know that colored
fella that works in the lobby he worked
there for 30 years while i was at cnn
and i
i was so excited to see him when i came
to visit
and i said and i said n word ronnie how
are you and i like larry can't do that
anymore
ronnie didn't seem to mind i always
tipped him well
uh he also had a pretty good sense of
humor about himself too he was never
really uh
too hung up on no remember he went on o
a and they
they they had been ripping him right on
him and he was such a good sport about
it yeah
like remember the the and what happened
to the groceries
there's that [ __ ] moment there was
the uh how important is the glove
i forget it was either the glove or the
ball the bat he was asking somebody how
important is the
and the question was like literally the
tool of their trade
it's like how important is the like
jesus larry
he was the best he did because it like
towards the end too like larry would
just
he he never did prep he would just come
in and go that's it we're gonna riff
i'm gonna talk to this guy but the
problem is as he got older
he also would zone out so he would just
come back
he'd snap back into the conversation and
just throw a wild pitch
just to see what seems anything he could
think of ah
man the goat i loved larry king i still
watch old clips about
it how long larry let's let's let's
watch a classic one
so somebody reminded me this is a
classic one oh this is the this is this
is
oh no okay lasted how long nine years
180 episodes
you gave it up right i did they didn't
cancel you
you canceled them you're not aware of
this no i'm john
i'm asking you you think i got cancelled
are you under the impression that i got
canceled i've hurt you jerry
i thought that was pretty well
documented this is the show is this
still cnn
don't most shows go down a little most
people do also you wouldn't but
yeah no i i went off there i was the
number one show on television larry
you were old you know who i am jewish
guy
brooklyn yes okay 75 million viewers
all right last episode did you ever see
the
uh the guy from ducktales the
larry klink letter larry king clip no no
what is it
look up larry i'm on ducktales i
actually just happened to watch this
weeks ago before larry king died
and i'd never seen this before it's one
of the funniest things that
it's a quick clip but from larry king
live but it's
oh the the dude from community yeah uh
but it's this is a very funny clip so
this is this is
this is larry's larry king now show
right yeah yeah yeah
uh a luxury you can't live without
a luxury i can't live without coffee
i really like luxury you can get it
anywhere
ah by the way he's so out of touch yeah
he's you get coffee i don't get coffee
anywhere in the world but listen to like
what larry thinks
this is one of the best clips ever
luxury you can get it anywhere
ah i guess yeah like good coffee
i love coffee too i like nice socks
socks
your socks would you put in your shoes
yeah i really love them i like kind of
like
you know cozy feet you're attracted to
yourselves
i'm attracted to really nice running
socks like i'm always looking for good
running
that's not a luxury though coffee and
socks or not a luxury all right give me
a luxury which what luxury should i have
private plane larry i'm on duck tales
i'm gonna miss you larry i haven't seen
that one i'm gonna miss you bud
i'm gonna miss you pal i haven't seen
that one
he's just he's to show
larry like [ __ ] he's always we used to
always joke about how joe rogan is so
out of touch but he's not a bad guy
like larry king strikes me as that kind
of guy too he's so out of touch
he's on a level that none of us will
even
even have a a scent of a whiff of in our
lifetime
and larry just lives that light and he
doesn't understand that like a private
plane
is not something that normal people do
this guy was all this guy was on a
sitcom and
[ __ ] duck tales it's not private
plane money larry among ducktales
he said it she said i gotta play that
just a lot of party game
which what luxury should i have private
plane
larry i'm on duck tales
that may be the best thing i've seen all
mine he's the best
that's the best thing i've seen all
month and this this what's funny is i
this popped in my uh timeline like a
month ago
before larry died just because like i
get larry king clips
recommended all the time because my my
algorithm is so autistic like mine's
super weird like yeah like i watch like
a lot of
edgy streamers and like irl ip2 people
but then i also watch a lot of old tom
snyder like reruns
so it's like it's recommending like you
know what i mean
baked alaska mesa's police officer and
then the next one's like
tom snyder don rickles interview 1989.
and you're like great okay this is
pretty cool so
i just got that recommended because it's
like oh well you love larry king like
you're all about that life and i watched
i was dying laughing
he's so out of touch i don't know
private plane you're not like a private
plane
i'm with you bali song i'm gonna watch
this whole interview after this show too
i'm watching this whole interview i have
to i have to
so i'm i'm on a private plane getting my
dick sucked by a 20 year old
from scandinavia you ever have that you
ever have that happen
that's never happened in my life
honestly i've never had one of those two
things larry
much less together um
nikki says i know exactly what tom
snyder clips channel is i love tom
snyder tom snyder was underrated man
he was another one when he died i was
kind of like ah it's a bummer man i
liked
i like thomas tom snyder was definitely
not a uh
he was an acquired taste he was not for
everybody but
i always liked tom snyder but larry king
is the [ __ ] goat
well
here's one here's here one more for you
since since he died we don't get to do
this often
larry king interviews larry king fred
arminson's playing larry by the way fred
armisen's larry king was whack compared
to norms
oh norm's the best news in my 25 years
at cnn
and i've saved my best guess for last
i'm talking to me
now larry what's been my favorite
interview
it's it's hard to pick one up you know
because you've done so many over the
years it's hard to pick one out
i hear the jew now you're such an
[ __ ]
just a little bit a little bit of
florida here's a little bit of florida
yeah i'd play the whole thing
uh yeah i know mcdonald's was but i love
definitely better yeah foreign
yeah because i've seen clips because if
you go look up like larry king snl
that's all fred armisen clips now and
it's like
they're not as good like norm's [ __ ]
larry king was the greatest thing ever
let's see
did you see norm mcdonald the last time
he was on larry king's show
where he was doing the where he was
doing it for him there's only no no
there's only one
it's a one-minute clip it's similar to
the ducktales thing it wasn't that long
ago what's something people don't know
about you
i'm a deeply closeted gay guy
no kidding well i'm not coming out
though
wait a minute what are you revealing
here today
i'm i'm not revealing anything i'm
saying i'm deeply closeted
well that means you're gay well i
wouldn't say
that why would i say that i'm cheaply
closeted
no but i that means you're very very gay
but you don't want to come out you're so
closeted
that i refuse to say i'm gay right
exactly but that doesn't that mean
you're gay
hey hey hey easy buddy
oh this book will reveal much
what a dick what a dick norm was
looks like that clip where he's like if
you ask me
there's no greater american living today
than josh brolin
it's like they just does clips of him in
my opinion
pound for pound chicken is the best meat
oh [ __ ] with the clicky clickity-clack
in the background typewriter
you should see us you should you can
there's some of them are on archive.com
you can listen to someone's
old like local radio south florida stuff
it's even crazier
uh man larry king larry king dead at
247.
yeah you know you think you would think
he would never die i thought he was
going to be with those that never dies
yeah i thought he'd live forever
yeah does he his last few assists in his
his show that he did on his own he
interviewed john cena
oh wow i'm sure that was a [ __ ]
highlight of it but that's my point like
the culture clash towards the end when
he was trying to do the youtube stuff
was pretty funny you know what i mean
yeah 50 cent he interviewed 50 cent
uh arsenio hall arsenio was
that guy got so much [ __ ] he got [ __ ]
on so bad
but probably one of the better late
night hosts
oh yeah no absolutely